[Music]
because the mayor is already
tired, he brings people from somewhere else, he
pays a thousand per vote. No, gentlemen, we no longer
want corruption. We are already tired
because we are not in the departments. There has been
a lot of problem.
Corruption,
manipulation of the ballots, even
bullets are evident.  there have been
and so we are not satisfied with that
[Music]
we will make
that trust the foundation
[Music] there
is a lot of insecurity because
people now go out to work and it is
difficult for us a little because we go out with
sadness there is a lot of insecurity and we
want  That someone stays and takes
control of Aha yes so that we can feel
a little more
relieved from all this crime
and
[Music]
that they do justice as much as possible, what I
ask them to do because in the street they
are going to give us one whoever
Someone who is like that and
has a good character eats you so that justice can be done
[Applause]